[Applause]
probably going to jump in one of those
hyperbaric chambers he uses for recovery
a Los Angeles Lakers will advance
a triple 125-85 win the Angelo Russell
is smiling again
he got his Vibe back tonight
and Darwin ham earns his first playoff
round Victory as a head coach
in his first test
[Applause]
the Grizzlies gave it a go short-handed
without Steven Adams without Brandon
Clark without Luke Canard today out with
a shoulder injury
the Lakers were simply better
[Music]
John Moran playing with that injured
right hand
gave it a decent run
ended up with 10 points and six assists
[Music]
they're embracing Phil handy
take a look at the updated bracket
brackets the seventh seed remember
defeat the number two seed technically
an upset you can call it what you want
Denver plays Phoenix tomorrow in game
one Saturday on TNT Anthony Davis
had some smoke for the guys that claim
they like going up the chimney
there'll be better endings in the future
for John Moran
[Applause]
he is a generational Talent who will
have better endings and better seasons
but this one belonged to the Lakers
Austin Reeves played a vital part as
well 34 minutes at 11 points six
rebounds four assists
Anthony Davis and team rent
22.